okay twitch says we're streaming
welcome to week eight
we're getting down to the end of the
course
congratulations to all of you who've
hung in for this long
just three weeks to go
so today i asked you to read the dynamo
paper
and so i want to say right off the bat
if you struggled with this paper
you're not alone this may have been the
first academic research paper that some
of you have read
at least the first that you may have
read for a class and it's different kind
of reading than you might be used to if
you try to plow right through from
beginning
to the end then that's not necessarily
the most effective way to read this kind
of paper so we can talk a little bit
about
strategies for reading research papers
especially since we're going to have
another reading assignment coming up in
about a week
but what i want to spend most of our
time on today
is discussing some of the cool
ideas that are in this paper so our
whole agenda today will be about
the dynamo paper so we're going to
quickly
review
some of the old ideas that we already
talked about
last time and previously in the course
so
and we'll discuss how they come up in
the paper
so um
review of old ideas
this will include availability
network partitions
eventual consistency
application specific conflict resolution
and there's more right but that's that's
kind of the main highlights that we're
going to talk about and then we'll talk
about some new things
that we haven't yet discussed in the
class but uh but do come up in the paper
so this will include
anti-entropy
with merkle trees
gossip
quorum consistency
tail latency
and then of course there's also more but
i think that's about what we'll have
time for for today
all right so let's jump in i want to try
to contextualize this little bit before
i start talking about this whole laundry
list of topics first i want to i guess
i'll add something to the beginning here
it's just like
why why are we reading this paper who
cares
so i want to say a little bit about why
this paper was important
and influential so the dynamo paper came
out in 2007
and it really influenced the way in
which a lot of people
conducted systems research
and uh so
before this paper there was a lot of
focus
on strong consistency and not only that
but the focus was on strong consistency
and especially
unforgiving settings like for example
settings where
uh where there were byzantine faults and
so
then the dynamo paper came along and
they said
not only do we not care about byzantine
faults
not only do we not care about security
right because this paper mentioned that
they're they're only operating they're
talking about a context in which they're
only running on
machines that are in amazon data centers
and they're not worried about those
machines being compromised right
so they're not worried about that stuff
not only do we not care about any of
that
we don't even care about having strong
consistency
so their priorities are very different
than what a lot of the
kind of preceding or popular work at the
time was doing
so the in the olden days the assumption
was that of course you needed to have
strong consistency and that was
considered
practically an answered question and so
people had kind of moved on to working
on other things like byzantine fault
tolerance and so on
and then amazon came along and their
priorities were totally different
and so this was really in some ways
revolutionary
and it kind of heralded a shift in what
the focus would be
in systems research for the next 10 15
years
and i have to say i don't personally
love the writing
of the dynamo paper i think that some of
the writing is just
not great and um
but it's but i think it's a terrific
paper to read in terms of
how it connects with this class and how
it touches on a whole lot of concepts
that we've already discussed
so now that you've actually looked at
the paper hopefully these are some of
the concepts
that we talked about so far in this
class that play some sort of a role
in dynamo so so let's talk about these
these old ideas
so availability
this is a big one so how did we define
availability remind me
when we talked last time how did we
define this notion of availability
yeah that's right we said something like
every request will receive a response
so that's one way to talk about
availability we could also say something
like
every request gets a response quickly or
we could talk about it in a sort of
probabilistic way we could say
99.9 percent of requests get a response
quickly so these are all
ways to talk about availability but
to a first approximation it's something
like this all requests
receive a response so if somebody wants
to make an update say put something in a
shopping cart
then you go ahead and let them do it no
matter what
network partition no problem you just
you don't want to wait around to get
acknowledgements from all the replicas
you serve the request and you respond to
the client
no matter what so that's a big one
and that's a huge factor in the design
of dynamo
i just mentioned network partitions
tied to this topic of availability so
this is another big one
what is a network partition
anybody
all right all right shark seeding
undersea optic fiber optic cable
sure okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so network partition is when you have
some machines in part of the network
that can't communicate with some
machines in another part unable to reach
machines in another part
so
some machine or machines can't talk to
others
network partitions are temporary
and they're unintentional
so i'm not talking about like a network
topology here where you would
intentionally make it so one machine
doesn't
communicate directly with another
machine instead i'm talking about a
situation where you have some machines
that are supposed to be able to talk to
each other
but for some temporary period of time
can't
and then there's this topic of eventual
consistency
which goes hand in hand with talking
about
availability and network partitions if
you want to
offer high availability and partition
tolerance
you may have to relax your consistency
requirements
and now as we discussed last time this
property of eventual consistency
fundamentally belongs in a different
category from those consistency models
we talked about so we talked about
strong consistency and causal
consistency and so on eventual
consistency
belongs in a different category because
it's a liveness property
and it says that replicas eventually
agree
more specifically it says that if
updates stop arriving the replicas will
come to agree
now this might seem like a kind of silly
definition because in practice updates
never may stop arriving
but it's a useful uh
and of rule of thumb so i wouldn't put
eventual consistency in a hierarchy
along with strong consistency causal
consistency and the rest
not even at the very bottom of that
hierarchy because it's a different kind
of property
all of those consistency models are
safety properties
this one's a liveness property
so what about safety in the context of
dynamo well
i think it's hard to say exactly what
safety property you get from dynamo
in terms of consistency you recall we
talked last time about a safety property
called strong convergence which is the
property that if two replicas
have gotten the same set of updates
possibly in different orders
then their states will agree so that's a
safety property
and that's a part of what we talked
about that's known as strong eventual
consistency
which is a property that has a safety
component and a liveness component
but the dynamo paper doesn't actually
claim to offer strong convergence or a
strong eventual consistency in fact
those were ideas that kind of popped up
a few years later
and by the way amazon did not invent
this concept of eventual consistency so
this term
eventual consistency was coined by doug
terry
and his colleagues uh to describe a
system that they built called bayou
in the in the mid 90s
so if you want to know more about that
look up look up bio
it's really interesting but amazon
although they did not invent this term
eventual consistency they certainly
popularized it to the point that now a
lot of people
think that amazon invented this concept
and i've been guilty of this myself i've
cited
amazon's work or work by amazon people
when i've needed to cite this concept of
eventual consistency
okay so we've talked about all these
things
uh we also talked a little bit about
application specific conflict resolution
this is that situation where you might
have one replica that
uh that has something in a shopping cart
uh like a book
and you have another replica that has
something else in a shopping cart like a
blender
and the client gets to figure out
what to do
with those conflicting
uh states so the client gets to figure
out that what it's actually supposed to
do
is take the union in the case of uh of
shopping carts
so i don't know if you saw but there's a
little footnote in the dynamo
paper about this it was actually really
interesting they say
that with the conflict resolution
mechanism that they're using for
shopping carts
there's a bug
does anybody remember does anybody
remember
who might have happened to read the
paper and see that footnote do you
remember what they said the bug is
well you're thinking about that there's
a question in chat
based on the dynamo paper wouldn't
always allowing rights be a safety
property in this scenario in which
systems may be failing
so if you're talking about availability
availability is a
is a liveness property for sure if you
want you can insert the word eventually
here
if that helps it looks a little look a
little bit more like a liveness property
to you
if you're thinking more in terms of
every request gets a response within a
certain time out
then that's starting to sound a little
bit more like a safety property because
that's something that actually could be
violated within a finite execution
that's not necessarily the classical way
of reasoning about availability
classically
we think of availability as being a as
being a liveness property
okay does anybody remember what the
dynamo shopping cart bug was
this was only mentioned really in
passing in the paper so it's okay
if you if you didn't
yeah that's right so the good so the
the bug is that deleted items can
reappear in a cart
why why do you think that can happen
well it has to do with this way of
resolving conflicts
so if one replica knew about
one item in the shopping cart like this
book and another replica knew about
another totally different copy of the
shopping cart containing
something like this blender and then the
client takes the union of them
then that's all fine and good right but
let's say yeah you're right so somebody
just mentions merging with an unupdated
replica or maybe
it could be something like this what if
one of the replicas has found out about
uh
both updates let's say one replica is
found out about the book
and the blender
and then so then we have this other
replica over here
uh which maybe just had the book
so at that point we're still fine right
like the union of these is still
uh what we want right the union of of of
these two sets is still book and blender
one of each
uh and the book has maybe been copied
over here but then let's say that this
replica decides to remove the book
so now we have an empty set here the
empty set is being unioned with this set
containing both
and that again gives you the book in the
blender
so the replica that did the delete if
the delete didn't propagate over
to the other replica uh before this
query is made
then this deleted item could pop up
again because there still could be a
copy of it elsewhere
i think this is really interesting this
notion you know we talk about
replication as a way to
uh to tolerate faults right we don't
want to lose our data
we don't want to lose our data so we
replicate it seems like a good idea
however when you want to get rid of
something
then replication can be your enemy and i
was talking to a friend at google a
while ago about this who was talking
about
compliance with the with with
the gdpr which is a european law that
has to do with
with privacy and not storing user data
one of the issues that my friend was
dealing with
was in order to comply with the law
they had to make sure that all copies of
certain user data were removed
and making sure that all copies are
removed in a replicated system can be
extra challenging
so this is really interesting right
it would seem that deletion
is different from addition right if
you're only adding to item
items to carts then it's not a problem
but it seems that the lesion has kind of
a
unusual relationship uh
with this conflict resolution mechanism
where we're trying to take the union
of different replicas so that's
something interesting to think
about and we'll talk a little bit more
about that a little bit later in the
course if we have time
okay so dynamo of course gets used for
all
kinds of things other than shopping
carts
so set union doesn't always make sense
to do
so they let you provide your own
conflict resolution mechanism
this is just one particular example of a
conflict resolution mechanism that you
could plug in and use with dynamo
that's why we call it application
specific right this is what might make
sense for the shopping cart service
but for something else some other
mechanism might be better
you get to specify it on your own what
does dynamo do
if you don't provide your own conflict
resolution mechanism what does dynamo do
then
does anybody remember
that's right yeah
it takes the latest write so
i'll say application specific con
conflict resolution or
lww which stands for last right wins
if you don't have any application
specific conflict resolution mechanism
to help it out
dynamo will use last right wins
so
questions about any of that
okay so here's a question for y'all
let's just think about shopping carts
for a second
ah there's a question about preference
lists
so i believe the notion of preference
lists in dynamo
doesn't have to do with conflict
resolution in that sense i believe that
has to do with
to whom you replicate so i think that
was a different notion of
of of preference but we'll talk about
that more later if not today then
on thursday okay so here's a question
for you all
let's just think about shopping carts
and for now um
let's just think about adding items to
shopping carts
so with addition of itings to addition
of items to shopping carts we have this
really nice property
that rights commute with each other and
we don't care about the order they
arrive
so if i add the book
and then the blender that's going to be
the same as if i add the blender
and then the book because we're treating
both of those as sets
right and sets don't have an order
so
rights commute what does commutativity
mean by the way
when i say that rights commute with each
other well
if we're talking about uh grade school
math
grade school arithmetic um we say that
uh addition is commutative for example
so
so the addition operation is commutative
so that means that a plus b equals b
plus a so changing the order of the
operands doesn't change the result
so when i say that rights commute with
each other
i'm sort of using the notion of
commutativity in a different way here
because i'm no longer talking about a
binary operation
but it's the same basic idea that order
doesn't affect the result
um so here's my question for you
with shopping carts we have this this
nice commutativity of rights
and that by itself is really nice
because that's enough to give us strong
convergence
remember strong convergence is this
property that we talked about which says
that if you've received the same set of
updates in some order
then your states will agree so if the
rights are commutative that'll give you
strong convergence
but the dynamo paper doesn't only do
that
it also talks about vector clocks so why
do we also need vector clocks
well so normally vector clocks would be
for enforcing
causal consistency or causal delivery or
something like that
but they didn't promise causal
consistency in this paper
so what are we what do we have the
vector clocks for if we're doing
shopping carts
what do you need them for i think
it's to minimize those sort of deletion
anomalies
that that footnote was about so the
vector clocks are
able to rule out most of the deletion
anomalies
you're still occasionally going to have
a deletion anomaly where you've deleted
something and then it reappears in the
cart
but they've decided that they're okay
with that
okay so every now and then
you're gonna get into a situation where
replicas disagree
and maybe even one of them is going to
have an update that's causally later
than the other according to their vector
clocks or maybe they disagree
because of something that vector clocks
can't help with maybe they disagree
because of concurrent updates
but one way or another you're in a
situation where replicas disagree
so one of the challenges here in the
first place is
finding out that they disagree so if i'm
standing here and drawing lan port
diagrams for you then
we have a god's eye view of what's going
on in the whole system and the whole
execution
and you can see that there's
disagreement
but how do nodes within the system
figure out that they may disagree with
nodes in the other system
if one replica thinks
that say x is three
does it have any way of necessarily
finding out that somebody else thinks
that x is four no not necessarily
so dynamo has a couple of mechanisms in
place
that will allow the system to find out
about
and resolve those sorts of conflicts
so i should stay here step one
find out that they disagree
this is not something that we've spent
much time on yet in this course we
haven't had to think about this mostly
because
we've either been dealing with
mechanisms that only do strongly
consistent replication
and so we haven't had to worry about
replicas disagreeing by the time that
our response gets back to the client
or it just hasn't been our concern right
like when we talk about causal
consistency
causal consistency can lead you to a
situation where replicas do
disagree because they could get
concurrent updates right and causal
consistency
doesn't rule out those sorts of
concurrent updates
but in practice you might want to do
something about it if replicas disagree
so dynamo has a couple of mechanisms
that we'll discuss
one of those mechanisms is called
anti-entropy
another one is called gossip
the way this works in dynamo is
every so often say once per second
a node will randomly pick another node
and will contact it and ask it what its
state is
so to be very clear there are two
different things being discussed here
when the paper talks about anti-entropy
they're talking about resolving
conflicts
in application state
and by this i mean the application is a
key value store
right dynamo is a key value store so by
this i mean
differences in the actual key value
pairs that are being stored the data the
actual data that's being stored
when the paper talks about gossip
it's talking about resolving a different
kind of conflict
does anybody remember
what kind of state we're talking about
when we talk about gossip
gossip is about resolving conflicts in
something other than the application
state does anybody remember
what kind of state is being talked about
the view good yeah so think back to when
we talked about different kinds of
problems that all amount to consensus
problems
this had to do with one of those so the
problem one of the problems that we
talked about was the group membership
problem the problem of knowing
which nodes are actually up which nodes
are actually participating in the system
well that's another kind of state that
has to be kept consistent between
replicas so
in addition to the actual data being
stored they all have to keep track
of what nodes are up
so you could call this view state
and view means who's up
in dynamo this is done via this
mechanism called gossip
and the current view of membership is
only eventually consistent
just like the data is only eventually
consistent
so once per second there's this gossip
thing
where a node contacts another node to
say hey what's your view
of who's up and running and gradually
they all figure it out
what i find really interesting about
this is that
in the paper they say they used to have
a mechanism that maintained a globally
consistent view
so i take that to mean that they used to
have a mechanism
that uh that gave them strong
consistency for views
but then they figured out that they
didn't need it
so they do gossip instead and that ends
up being good enough
so there's this interesting bit of
historical background in the paper where
they say
hey we used to try to do something more
challenging for
trying to keep the views consistent and
then we figured out that we could just
get away with doing this gossip thing
where we just have replicas periodically
contact each other and say hey who's
your view
so dynamo has these two different
but similar mechanisms in place
for resolving conflicts in application
state the actual key value pairs that
are being stored
and resolving conflicts in group
membership state meaning the node's
views of
which other replicas are up and running
and yes there's a question in chat about
how this relates to what we're doing for
assignment three yeah so
the part of the assignment that involves
views
you could implement something like like
dynamo's gossip
for the part of the assignment that
involves the actual key value
state for that we're not
asking you to necessarily implement
something like anti-entropy because
the why do we need anti-entropy well
anti-entropy is for ensuring something
that's
actually better than causal consistency
you know how we talked about you can end
up in a situation where replicas
disagree because of concurrent rights
like this
this replica over here could end up
thinking that x is 4 and this one could
end up thinking that x is 3 because
clients have concurrently written those
things even in a causally consistent
system
you could end up that way what
anti-entropy does
is it tries to resolve those kinds of
conflicts
by having having nodes talk to one
another
tell each other what their state is
so in general these two words
are synonyms right and anti-entropy is
is just a kind of a fancy way to say
gossip
but in the context of the dynamo paper
they mean different things so i'm going
to say synonyms in general
but have but they have different
meanings in dynamo
okay so gossip and anti-entropy are both
for
resolving conflicts in some kind of
state
but then you might ask yourself
why do we need two different mechanisms
right if they're both for resolving
conflicts in state
how are these two problems different
practically speaking
how is it different how is resolving
conflicts and application state
different from resolving conflicts in in
view state
in terms of your practical
implementation and the concerns that you
might have practically speaking
what's the difference
there must be some difference right
because otherwise they wouldn't bother
to have these two distinct
mechanisms that they give different
treatment to in the paper
what do you think
yeah okay so there's a comment that with
viewstate we need to know who's up so
that we can make progress but
yeah okay but i think you might also
need to know
how to i think you might also need to
resolve uh conflicts and application
state to be able to make progress
okay so let's think about it this way
if replicas are sending around
information to each other
about what their current state is
how big are those states going to be if
it's the view state
how much information is that well it's
probably not very much information right
it's just going to be like a list of
some machines
and maybe not very many right a handful
maybe maybe a few dozen maybe
you know at most you know 100 i don't
know
not that many but what about application
state well how many key value pairs are
you talking about right how many key
value pairs could you have on a
particular replica
you could have a whole lot couldn't you
so in the case of application state
the amount of state that you're talking
about
could be much much larger
with this view state you you essentially
just have some
small list of nodes
right you have a list of some relatively
small number of nodes but
for application state you could have a
lot of key value pairs
so
change in size means we have to change
our approach
right so given that these application
states are so large
it's not going to be feasible for
replicas to send their complete
state to each other all the time right
it would take a lot of bandwidth so what
do they do
instead what does dynamo do
to minimize the cost of data transfer
when it's trying to do this anti-entropy
data synchronization
that's right you don't want to send a
gigabyte over the wire if you can help
it right
so what does dynamo do to make this big
thing less big
good yeah dynamo uses something
called merkle trees also known as hash
trees
so how does dynamo minimize data
transfer cost during anti-entropy
with merkel trees
also known as hash trees
so a merkle tree looks something like
this
so you've got some pieces of data
any data in the case of dynamo there's
the data will be key value pairs but it
doesn't really matter what they are
merkle trees will work with any kind of
data
so let's just say that i have some
blocks of data like this
so at the leaves of the tree i'm
starting at the bottom of the trade i'm
going to draw up you have
these chunks of data and then
you take the hash of each chunk of data
using some hash function
so those are the leaf nodes of the tree
and then for the non-leaf nodes
every node is going to store the hash of
its children
so the parent here
is gonna it's gonna combine the hash of
its uh children somehow so maybe we'll
take the hash
of one maybe we'll concatenate it with
the hash of two
and then we'll take the hash of all that
similarly over here
so to make this a little bit easier to
write let's give some names
to these things so let's call this
this which is one big hash value let's
call it a
and let's call this
hash value b and so then up here
the parent of those is going to be the
hash
of a and b
and that's the root
so these are our data right this might
be like some key value pairs
and so on
so the leaves of the tree you have
hashes of each chunk of data
and for the non-leaf nodes every node is
going to store the hash of its children
so in this case it happens to be a
binary tree
so the non-leaf nodes have two children
and the way that i've done it is just
that they're concatenating together the
their children's hash values so this
plus here could be concatenation
and then take the hash of that and so on
up to the root
so this hash value up here at the root
is incorporating information about all
of the hash values under it
what's the purpose of doing all this
why do we bother to do all this
right so we want to minimize the amount
of data to compare good
what will this what this will do is
it'll make it easier to quickly compare
large amounts of data
so let's say for instance that we have
two replicas
so let's we let's say that we have
replica one
and replica one has some key value pairs
replica 2 has some key value pairs
and maybe replica 2 is only a little
different
in particular let's say that replica 2
only differs in the value of this one
key
y
it would be really really expensive for
replica one to have to send its whole
state over to replica 2
or for replica 2 to send its whole state
over to replica 1. and it especially
seems ridiculous
because there's only this one this one
point of disagreement right
but you don't know that until you talk
to the other replica
how are you going to quickly find out
that there's only this one point of
disagreement between the replicas so
that's where merkle trees come in
so in this case no maybe
i'll put y i'll put this over here
so maybe
this is what the merkle tree looks like
on replica one
so this data item number two is going to
be different
on those two replicas since uh
the hash of this item number two is
going to be different as well
so then the parent here
where we're concatenating hash one and
hash two is also going to be different
on the two replicas and finally the root
will be different
so to compare their state
replicas can start by comparing the root
of the merkle tree
so each of these replicas will be
storing uh
this merkle tree when they have to
compare their state with each other
during this anti-entropy process
the first thing that they can do is
merely send over this root hash
so it's one little hash value that says
something that kind of summarizes the
whole state
of of the the key value pairs at that
moment
if their hash values agree at the root
then great then you know that all the
underlying data is going to be the same
at that point
if the root nodes disagree then you have
to look further for the difference
so in this case you can send over
these two next level down hashes these
two child hashes like
the hash here and the hash here well if
the replicas are like this
then they're going to agree um
let's see it was this one that was
different right this is the one this is
the only one that differed between
the two replicas so this this value will
agree
between these two replicas and so
that'll tell it okay
i don't have to look any further down
that side of this binary tree
instead i need to keep looking here
so then we'll compare those hash values
and so on and so you'll keep on going
until you get to the point of
disagreement
so child a will differ because um
because of this um this this value being
different and so it's going to have a
different hash
so we can then zero in on a and look at
its children right and then figure out
that it's this item number two that
differs
and we figured it out by only comparing
this relatively small number of hash
values
and we only had to send those over the
network instead of sending lots and lots
of data
so merkle trees are really nice they're
used in all kinds of systems not only
k-value stores like this they're really
handy anytime that you have to compare
large data sets especially if you need
to do so over a network where network
bandwidth
is a is a scarce resource
so if you want to you can go look up
merkle trees and read about them on
their own on your own
they're called merkle trees uh because
they were invented by somebody with the
last name of merkel so it's kind of a
silly name
uh i believe that individual actually
has a patent
on them but um hash trees is a slightly
less silly name but somehow
the name merkle trees seems to have
caught on so that's what everybody calls
them
questions about any of that
so another place that you might see
merkle trees used is if you want to
check the authenticity of data if you
have a copy of some data
and you want to make sure that it
compares to some other authentic source
but it's maybe it's a huge data set
right
so going through all of the data and
checking the veracity of all of that
data might be really expensive to do
what you can instead do is use a
mechanism like this
it's kind of like with checksums right
so if you're familiar with the notion of
a checksum
that tells you a kind of summary of
what's uh
of some much larger piece of data so you
can figure out does my data match yours
by by computing a checksum
if the checksums disagree then you know
that the data doesn't match now it's not
a perfect
uh uh
summary right maybe the checksums agree
but still the data might disagree
right but you do know for sure that if
the checksums disagree then so does the
data
so similarly with merkle trees
we try to we we try to use a hash
function
that you know we try to use uniform hash
function and all that good stuff it
doesn't necessarily have to be a
cryptographically secure hash function
because
as they say in the dynamo paper they
don't care about that right
they trust everybody involved they only
care about saving bandwidth
in this paper they care about minimizing
data transfer costs they're not worried
their threat model does not include
uh machines being compromised right
uh but what they do care about is making
sure that they don't send too much data
over the network when they're trying to
resolve conflicts in application state
so that's what merkel trees are for one
of the things that merkel trees can be
used for
any questions about that
i have a blog post that i can point you
to if you're curious so
a student asked a question once um
when i was teaching this course about um
what would happen
if these replicas actually had different
sets of
of key value pairs right like
what if replica 2 didn't have this one
well
how would you how would you make these
trees agree right
like you want you want the data to be
organized in the same way
um otherwise you won't otherwise the
comparison of the hashes won't be
meaningful
so i have a blog post that i can point
you to
that's about that and
i don't think it's necessarily so
important for the purpose of this class
um but um because it's not it's it's uh
it's kind of an aside
um but i'll uh i'll share it
on zulip later
okay so i think now is a good time to
pause
and do our quiz question
and it's currently 4 14 so let's come
back at 4 24.
right see you in 10 minutes
two minute warning
okay welcome back
right shifting gears to a different
topic
so another concept that i want to touch
on that we have not
talked about yet in this course is the
concept of quorum
consistency
so in replication strategies like
primary backup or chain replication
clients would only talk to particular
nodes right so in the case of primary
backup clients only talk to the primary
and in chain replication clients only
talk to the head for rights and the tail
for reads
but in dynamo it's different so in
dynamo the client can actually
talk to any replica or all of them so no
replica is going to play a distinguished
role so it's kind of similar actually to
what you're implementing for the
assignment
so suppose that we have a client
and let's say that we have three
replicas
oops
that's supposed to be letter r
so in this setting the client is
actually aware
of all of these nodes
and the client is able to talk to any or
all of them so in some sense
this is kind of interesting the client
actually kind of starts to resemble the
primary from primary backup replication
because recall what the primary does in
primary backup it goes out and talks to
all the replicas and gets responses from
all of them
so if the client wanted to it could go
out and ask every node a question and
get responses from all of them if it
wants to know
the value of a particular key let's say
it could ask all the nodes
get responses from all of them but how
many
does it have to talk to how many should
it talk to
so in quorum systems this is something
that you can configure
so quorum systems let you configure how
many replicas you can talk to
so there are three important variables
that are configurable in a quorum system
so n is the number of replicas
so here n happens to be three
w which is called the right quorum
this is how many replicas
have to acknowledge a right
for it to be considered completed
and then it may not surprise you to
learn that they read purim
is how many replicas
have to acknowledge you
before you can consider a read operation
to have completed
so clearly w and r here are both going
to be at most
n but they could be less than it
so let me toss an idea out there let's
suppose that we have this three replica
system
and let's say that we use the following
settings
so n is three
let's set w to three and r to one
so in other words when you do a write
you have to write to everybody
and when you do a read you just read
from one
this is kind of a subtle question but
let me ask it this way would this give
you
strong consistency
what do you think think about that for a
moment
now some professors like to do polls for
things like this
but um i mean i think it's actually kind
of a subtle question so i think it's
worth spending a little time talking
about instead of just saying a yes or no
answer
yeah good question so the question in
chat is
don't the strongly consistent
replication techniques that we talked
about already
already demonstrate this yeah so this
kind of looks a lot
like primary backup or chain replication
doesn't it with primary backup and chain
replication we have to do the right on
everybody
and we only read from one so
that's an argument for why this might
give you strong consistency yeah
but i would argue that it's maybe a
little bit more subtle than that
right because when we're talking about
those strongly consistent replication
techniques of
of primary backup and chain replication
we're talking about a setting where the
client only is going to talk to a
designated one of the replicas
right the client's only going to talk to
a particular one
then that replica's job is to go out and
talk to everybody else
and then that then it's another
particular replicas job either the
primary if it's primary backup or the
tail
in chain replication uh to respond to
the client
and the that and that response recall
that that's the commit point
right so that commit point is very
important
right the commit point is the point at
which you know
that everybody's gotten that right
but what if you have something like this
what if uh
what if you have concurrent rights so
what if
uh what if this client is writing to all
these replicas here
maybe writing x
and then maybe just doing a read from
one of the replicas
and this is all fine and good but what
if another client comes along
and maybe that client is using a similar
approach maybe they're also using that
sort of
read one approach and write to three
approach
when we were doing primary backup and
chain replication let's say just let's
talk about primary backup
as an example the role of the primary
is to determine the order of rights
so the primary serves as a sort of
synchronization point
that decides on the order of rights and
is going to send them out
to the backups in that order
but there's no such synchronization
point here
so if these rights come in in a
different order
then you could still end up with
replicas disagreeing
so this sort of quorum consistency
approach this is called
there's a name for this it's called read
one write all
or rawa
for short
so this kind of approach could still
lead to a situation in which you don't
have strong consistency
so the three rights
would need to occur as a transaction
that gets ordered a particular way
in order for this approach to actually
give you strong consistency so
that's an entire topic i think and i
don't have really room to cover it in
this course but
in any case um
this is an approach that does get used a
lot
and it does give you you know something
good
right it lets you make sure that your
your right is saved in three different
places it makes you lets you make sure
that your right
has has been actually landed
on all these replicas before you do a
read
it doesn't say anything about whether
other rights may or may not sneak in
so it's not quite the same as what you
get from something like
something something like primary backup
so that's one issue there's also another
reason not to do this
um and it's the same kind of issue you
get with things like primary backup or
chain replication
which is that it's not fault tolerant in
the sense that
if a node crashes or if there's a
network partition here
that separates some nodes from the
client then
we can't consider a right to have
completed so
if the right quorum is the same as the
number of replicas
but there's some partition that's
separating uh
some of the replicas from the client
then the client
uh the client can't do any rights you
can't say that the rights have
necessarily completed
and primary backup and chain replication
have the same problem
until they detect the failure and then
remove the failed node and
update everybody's view and all of that
stuff
and then of course in other issues that
rights are just slow right if you have
to wait for everybody to acknowledge the
right
and then it takes a while maybe so
kind of same issue as we see with
primary backup and chain replication
rights are slow
so it may not surprise you to learn
that this read one write all setting
is not what the dynamo paper suggests
using
so in answer to this question would this
give you strong consistency
uh i'm going to say not necessarily
and in any case it's not what the dynamo
paper suggests
in fact and you might have
seen this if you looked at the the
experiments near the end of the paper
uh when you have three replicas what do
they actually suggest doing
how do they suggest setting these right
this right quorum in this read forum in
the in the dynamo paper
it's kind of interesting what they
choose to do
so just to be clear strong consistency
is totally out the window
we're giving up on that with dynamo
exactly yeah so you want to read and
write two out of the three
so they suggest doing
a read program of two and a right quorum
of two so
what does that end up looking like what
happens then
well now i think we're getting pretty uh
pretty complicated here so maybe we
should switch over to
drawing lan port diagrams
so let's say we have our client and our
replicas
ah that's better now we can talk about
time okay so
let's say that we do a write of a
particular key and then we read it
so let's say that i'm going to write a
key like x is 5.
so we said that the right quorum was two
so that means that i have to write to
two at least
so let's say that i write to these two
and let's say that they both acknowledge
and now i want to do a read
well i have to read from too
well maybe i'm lucky and i read from the
same ones that i just
wrote to but maybe i'm not lucky so
maybe i'm going to read over here
so this is one of the ones that i wrote
to before
so this one knows that x is 5 but maybe
this one thought something else
so when we get back answers
we're not necessarily going to get back
from every
one of our reads the same thing that we
previously
wrote however notice that the read and
write quorums overlap
so
in particular if you add the read and
write quotes together you get something
that's bigger
than the the total number of nodes that
there are
so you know that you're going to get at
least
one response that has that latest right
now how do you figure out which of these
is what you actually want you know five
and four
well that's your problem right you might
not have uh the best conflict resolution
strategy
and that's on you to figure out as the
client but at least you know
that somebody's gonna tell you the most
recently written data
no sometimes
the notion of read quorum is defined
differently so i only defined it before
as how many replicas have to respond to
a read operation
sometimes you'll see papers that say or
you'll see settings of books where they
say
a a read quorum of two means you have to
hear back from at least two with the
same value
so i've seen it defined that way in some
places but i don't think that's what the
dynamo paper means by it
so in general if you have this property
uh that the read quorum and the right
quorum together
are greater than the total number
then you know that every read quorum
is going to intersect with every right
quorum
and so you know that you won't get
what's known as a stale read you know
that somebody is going to send you back
the most recently written data there's
kind of more to say about this but um
but that's kind of the the short version
so in quorum systems you can configure
these numbers
and so
cassandra for example is an example of a
of a data store that lets you do this
and there are others as well so you can
tune these numbers
to kind of get what you want right if
you want it to be really really easy
to do rights then your right quorum will
be lower
but then your fault tolerance is
correspondingly less
right like if only one replica has to
respond to
uh to a right and then that replica
immediately crashes
then that's not great on the other hand
if replicas are gossiping between each
other
then you know replica 3 over here that
didn't get the right well you know maybe
sooner or later it'll find it out right
you know maybe here maybe you'll be
lucky maybe the right will land over
here
and then you will hear back from
everybody at the same time but you saved
time right because you didn't have to
wait
for that query to go all the way to
replica 3 and then get and then for the
acknowledgement to get all the way back
to you
just to be able to do the right in the
first place so
you've saved some time and maybe most of
the time it'll be good enough
that's a trade-off that you have to
think about when you're choosing
what these settings should be for r and
w in a set in a system that supports
this kind of thing
okay there's only one more topic that's
on my agenda today
and this is actually something that i i
don't always teach about
um but i realized as i was
thinking back uh looking back at the at
the dynamo paper this is really
something that's very
important and they bring it up
repeatedly
so i think it's something that we should
talk about
tail latency okay so
before we talk about this somebody
refreshed my memory on how we defined
latency
what do we mean when we talk about
how long it takes to get a response yeah
time between the start and the end of
the action time
between invocation and a response
so another way to say that is how long
it takes to get a response
so let's say that you have a system
that's serving a whole bunch of requests
and you know maybe it's a key value
store like dynamo or like the one that
you're implementing
uh but some kind of system that
responds to requests so naturally you
care about what the latency is
right you want those requests to be
served quickly well let's say that you
have
collected some data about latency so
um
i'll just make up some numbers here so
let's say that some requests only take
uh
say one millisecond to service
and then you know if you're unlucky some
requests take a lot longer like maybe
they take
10 milliseconds and then if you're
really unlucky they might take like a
hundred
so let's say that you've gathered a
bunch of data over time about how long
it takes
to uh to respond to a request
um so you know if it's a fairly typical
system
um so maybe this axis over here is a
number of requests
um so this is like a low number here
like zero and then this is a higher
number like a thousand or something
let's say a hundred so then you have
something like
some kind of a curve that looks like
this where you know maybe a lot of
requests get served quickly
and then you have this long tail that
kind of tails off like that
so the shape of this curve
which you know might not not be you know
entirely accurate or to scale or
whatever but you might have something
that's shaped a lot like this
right where uh a lot of your
requests you know the great majority of
them are getting served you know
very quickly and then you have this sort
of long tail here
of not very many requests but um
some but those requests take a really
long time
so here's the thing let's say that you
have that picture
and then i'll draw a different picture
here
where the labels on the axes are the
same and every everything's the same
but let's just say that the tail is a
little bit shorter
so let's say that it's like this
um so let's say that this uh this system
that we're um
that we're looking at the the latency of
is you know some key value store that
you're
building you know for work
and um
uh and let's say that let's say that
this is what it looks like
and um and your boss asks you well
what's the average latency so
i don't know the average latency here
something
pretty low right like i haven't worked
it out exactly but let's say that
i don't know maybe it's something like
right here maybe this is average so
maybe the average latency
is three milliseconds
what about this one do you think that
the average latency in this picture
is much different from the average
latency in this picture up here
a little bit lower yeah
but probably not that much lower right
now what if this tail is really narrow
right like what if it's really narrow
so the average latency here might be
like
maybe it's like 2.8 milliseconds or
something like that right
now those two numbers don't look all
that different do they
and of course they don't look different
because the the great majority of the
requests that you're talking about are
all in this chunk over here
it's just this tail part that differs
and so that doesn't change the average
latency all that much
but your boss is really unhappy with
this
right they're really unhappy with this
and they're really happy with this
right so why why do they like this so
much better than this well
even though the average latency is you
know very very similar
well it turns out maybe we were
measuring the wrong thing
so we were looking at average latency
when really yep whoever just anticipated
in chat that maybe we were measuring the
wrong thing is correct
so really what you want to look at
is what the latency is like near the
tail end of the distribution
so you want to know something like
how slow were those requests
so in the dynamo paper they really they
harp on this quite a lot
they say what's the latency at the i
think the 99.9 percentile
well in this picture it might be really
bad it might be like
100 milliseconds and in this one it
might only be like 10.
so now this metric
is a lot more helpful right this metric
helps us see
what's much worse about this way of
doing things
so the 99.9 percentile and this one
might just be
like right here
so in other words if you have 100
requests we want to know
uh well maybe if it's a thousand that'll
make it a little bit easier to calculate
um if it's a thousand you want to know
the second slowest request out of those
thousand
that's the 99.9 percentile of the
distribution what was the second slowest
request
that is what people mean when they talk
about tail latency
the latency at the high end of the
distribution of all the requests
and they they um they emphasize this in
the in the dynamo paper because
they're very proud understandably that
dynamo has
good tail latency because they made a
particular effort to try to
try to minimize this tail latency now
when i said you're looking at the second
slowest request
right the requested 99.9 percentile if
it's a thousand requests it's going to
be you know
the the second slowest out of all those
requests why don't you look at the very
slowest one
well it's because in every system
there's going to be some weird behavior
right so out of a thousand requests you
know if there's
one that took really really really
really really really long
right if one if one request way out here
took 300 milliseconds
you have to draw the line somewhere
right maybe you don't care so much about
that
but what they determined in this
in this paper and you know more
importantly from their years of thinking
about it was that
the 99.9 percentile was something that
they really could
optimize for and then
in some later work that they did they
looked at the 99.99 percentile and so on
um but that's what they mean by that and
that's why they keep emphasizing this in
this paper because
they're trying to encourage other people
too to to talk about tail latency
and so hopefully you know this picture
kind of makes clear what that means
that's why they talk about it so much
all right we're out of time for today um
next time
we're going to talk about yet another
topic that comes up in the dynamo paper
which is consistent hashing
and that will take all the entire uh
class period next time uh so i will see
you on thursday
and enjoy working on assignment three
see you in a couple of days